and it will allow us to study the very
first galaxies that formed in the
universe
i'm dr mark klampkin i'm the director of
sciences and exploration here at the
goddess space flight center i came to
nasa from the space telescope science
institute and i basically started my
career working on technology to help
find planets around other stars
james webb is quite simply the largest
space telescope that we've ever launched
to do astrophysics in space my role when
i joined the garden space flight center
to work on james webb was serving as the
observatory project scientist i
sometimes refer to it as the science
police working with the engineers to
make sure that all the science
requirements for the observatory which
is the telescope and then all of the
hardware that makes the telescope work
met its science goals the big technical
challenges to do the science
are trying to build the telescope that's
much bigger than its precursor which was
the hubble space telescope so we went
from a two and a half meter size mirror
on hubble to a six and a half meters
size with the joints web space telescope
and james webb unlike hubble which
basically is designed to work in the
ultraviolet and the visible the james
webb was designed to work in the
infrared and that is heat radiation and
one of the major challenges anytime you
build a telescope to work in the
infrared is that you cannot see your own
thermal signature so the big challenge
has been to design a telescope that will
cool to about 40 degrees above absolute
zero so that the only signal that webb
is detecting is from the objects that
we're trying to study and the design
that we came up with is what we call
passive calling underneath it we have
this array of cat on membranes kept on
the same kind of material that they make
birthday balloons out of the backside of
these membrane layers are always looking
at the sun which means the telescope is
always looking out into space and that
way it can cool down to this operating
temperature of about 40 degrees above
absolute zero another big challenge has
been how do we actually fit a telescope
it's big inside a rocket fairing and
that has required us to actually fold up
the telescope and these membranes so
that it's kind of like a reverse origami
puzzle and once we launch and we deploy
the telescope we then unfold and unpack
everything so there's a lot of really
interesting technical challenges on this
telescope
with the hubble space telescope we've
taken these very deep images of what
look like blank areas on the sky called
the deep fields and when we collect
light for a very long time with hubble
what we find is that those so-called
blank areas are actually full of
galaxies and with hubble we've been able
to track these galaxies back to
something like a billion years after the
big bang occurred unfortunately because
the light is so red-shifted if we want
to look further back all the way to the
period about one to three hundred
million years after the big bang we have
to do the observations in the infrared
because all the light from these very
first galaxies is redshifted into the
infrared we also know that these
galaxies can be extremely faint so we
need a much bigger mirror to collect the
light from these very faint sources and
allow us to actually capture
images
one of the really great things about
hubble is that when we built it we built
it to do three or four major science
goals it achieved those science goals
but it also was such a major change in
capability it's been able to make
breakthroughs in just about every area
of astrophysics that were never even
contemplated when the telescope was
built and we really expect that with
where this is going to be the same we're
building it to study the very first
galaxies that occurred in the universe
to understand how the universe has
evolved over time closer into our own
galaxy we want to understand what the
life cycle of stars actually is and also
how planetary systems form around stars
so we have a lot of really interesting
science to be done with this telescope
we fully expect it's going to make
discoveries in areas that we can't even
think about right now
[Music]
you